ليديا والقبطان ، أنا كاتبة بعض الشيء ،
لكنني فنانة أفضل وإنسان ، كانت
معنوياتي التي أتت بسبب
الضرورة مرآة كبيرة كسرتها ابنتي
منذ بعض الوقت ، لذا قمت بتحطيمها لأنني
لم يكن
لدي ناكاتا وبدأت  لألصقها ، أنا
أحمل نفسي لا أعرف غرفتي ولكن من قبل
الزوج جعل الأمر يبدو وكأنني
لا أعرف ، وعندما عاد ،
لم يكن الأمر كذلك ، لذا بدأت في فعل الشيء نفسه
في  الجزء الخشبي وفعلت الشيء نفسه
مع المرآة ،
سألقي نظرة المنتصف على الانتقال ، لا كلما كانت
قطعة النقش أكبر حتى
تتمكن ابنتي من الكتابة في القطع الكبيرة التي تعرف أنها
سهلة بالنسبة لي لتنظيفها ولكن بعد ذلك في 79
عندما يصبح كل شيء مشهور قلته لرؤية
هذا المكان يزداد سوءًا يومًا بعد يوم
أسوأ ، اكتشفت أن النمل الأبيض يأكل
على لوحة الآن سأحصل على المشكلة
الآن ، وسأضطر إلى إخراج كل شيء
بدأته
ولم أقم به  الأرضية
والسوس الصغير المتحرك غير قادرين على الخروج
لأن المتحف كان تصميمًا ذريًا
للقناة والحالة الأولى  رسم
إيقاع الحائط رسم كلب في أي
حال وكانوا بسبب هذا حتى النساء
مختلفات ويكشف عن تجربة
[موسيقى]
كانت جميلة تي حفلة فتاة هنا
بطريقة ما الله خصب باتيل فرع
ولكن ما لديك لا يمكن أن تتحرك يوميا
حديث حاجمان أمريكا الليمون الشجاعة
إلى المرآب والمساواة
نعم أخبر الانتباه المصور
المقدس جهنم تجمع أفضل حالة
جهاد جهاد الثاني يمكنني أن أخبرك عن
الساعة 1 في 1 سنة 6 أشهر 3 أسابيع و 4
أيام
واو حسنًا لا يمكنني إخبارك بعد ذلك  صورة
عن حوالي 20 طنًا من المرآة لم أكن
أعرف أنه كان يأخذني عندما كنت أعمل ،
لقد كرهت ذلك لأنني أعني مليئة بجميع
الأصوات والأسمنت وأشياء من هذا القبيل ،
كنت بالفعل تحب أن تكون جميلًا كما
تعلم ، لذلك كنت نوعًا من  من فضلك لا
تأخذني الآن أنا في حالة من الفوضى ،
ربما إذا لم آخذك ، فلن
يعتقد أحد أنك ستفعلها ونستمر في
فعل ذلك في القطعة الأيونية و Maheu ثم
في الجائزة العالمية.
من المعلم الميكانيكي الذي أشعر بإضافة
تشان فقط  nel as nanny cam load Baja كان لديه
الجزء المثالي الذي سيكون قادرًا أو هنا من أجل
التشريحية سأعمل على
Tiffania والبطل الخاص بنا من المقلاة لكنني لا
أعرف حضن سيدة الساخنة على هذا أعطاني
شعورًا بالإنجازات التي أعطيها
الإنجاز الذي  لقد أوقفت النمل الأبيض
لأن هذه كانت طريقي لمنع
النمل الأبيض من أي شيء آخر وقد فعلت ذلك